buenas noches
el flamante primer ministro de perú
héctor baller pintó es un congresista es
abogado de profesión ingresó al
parlamento por el partido de derecha
renovación popular y luego se retiró
para formar la agrupación pero
democrático que apoya al presidente de
pedro castillo y otro personaje que
sobresale pero no precisamente por sus
logros profesionales es el actual nuevo
ministro del interior y alfonso chávarry
quien está alfonso chávarry es un ex
oficial de la policía peruana quien es
cuestionado por tener una sentencia por
abuso de autoridad en la institución
policial y también por tener dos
procesos por tráfico ilícito de drogas
el principal desafío de este nuevo
gabinete va a ser obtener el voto de
confianza en 30 días cuando se presente
al parlamento para presentar su plan de
gobierno desde ya diversos congresistas
han adelantado que no piensan apoyar un
gabinete ministerial en el cual uno de
sus integrantes es un es policía que
está implicado con casos de tráfico
ilícito de drogas francisco y este es el
tercer gabinete de pedro castillo en tan
solo seis meses que lleva en la
presidencia podrá este nuevo equipo
garantizarle la gobernabilidad
precisamente esa es la pregunta del
millón que se hace muchos peruanos en
momentos en que pedro castillo tiene un
6.9
66.9 por ciento de desaprobación de los
peruanos ya no le creen a este
mandatario ni al gobierno toda vez que
la renunciante primer ministro mitad
vázquez lo ha denunciado con una persona
que adolece de decisiones no tiene el
liderazgo para digamos sancionar en las
acusaciones a los funcionarios quienes
tiene sospechas de estar inmersos en
actos de corrupción o mal manejo del
gobierno esto va a ser digamos un punto
de quiebre para pedro castillo ejercer
un liderazgo a tender puentes con el
diálogo con diversos sectores del país y
en especial con la derecha que gobierna
el parlamento peruano